[Music]
and magical pervert news that's funny
our opera is magical politically well
because they like to do my nose itches
it's because they like to be perverse
and that's usually a very magical thing
cuz it's like an icy me know you don't
like own I see my dick night oh hey
submitted by Fried Chicken oh I love you
oh man I've been I've been on a fried
chicken and waffles kick lately no not
me
super star magician David Blaine no way
by the way guys [ __ ] crazy I love
that guy is being accused of rape I for
I do not like him at all always thought
he was a piece of time knew it it was
just a perfect pause how did he rape her
like you see me he does have that
perverted look cuz you know after he
does a trick he's always like looking
the wallet and you pull out it's her
name and it's always fun
I know exactly how he did this [ __ ] his
voice is I want you to look at your
[ __ ] they're coming their biggest crush
on David because I love that voice I
thought it was he looks like he's
partied all night and Vinny shower yeah
you like that look yeah yeah
yeah he probably smells like alcohol and
cigarettes on his leather jacket that's
exactly having sex with David Blaine
would be the most obnoxious thing on
earth I'm gonna come inside oh did you
not really check your ear magic trick
he's always gone textbook rapist I don't
know how no one could have got this yeah
he the textbook penis violates you and
then disappears without a trace violence
your mind or body so reading this thing
I was like oh no they catch I'm gonna
disappear down to jail too he is done
you probably had an alibi look how could
I raped her cuz I was in that [ __ ]
treasure chest all night yeah come on
Damon's voice is so monotone like I
would just be so like you know cuz
teenage girls are like super depressed
and want to be depressed like let me be
the Prez let's wear black and then like
kind of like we're together yeah dirty
but still pretty at the same time I
could make your pain yet here oh my god
you tilt his head like that - yeah
yeah this whole episode do this whole
episode boys I know what do it the best
one because you actually have a little
bear tone quality that we want me to say
oh that's it never heard that voice from
you to say in the summer of 2004 in the
summer of 2004 in London in London David
Blaine Wow a little bit younger Tiffany
loved him for that cuz I always had a
thing about my black dark circles and
I'm like we he hasn't he's gonna go off
ventilation people you used to look
different right like shoulder length
hair David Blaine looks like he looks
like the antidepressant version of Craig
David ticking me off
what's that him to that is not that's
not him that's Lenny Kravitz is Joe what
you taking me out yeah yeah so anyways
to the story here yes oh um circles yeah
we had same dark circles so Natasha
Natasha price this is Natasha former
model when she was a teen she'd come on
in a shit-ton of magazine covers so she
is claiming that back in the summer of
2004 uh Blaine David Blaine drugged her
and anally raped her in a bit
home that's what she's cleaning I
thought that sucks right that's all I'm
saying she just randomly remember 13
years later earlier okay so yeah that's
disgusting because she didn't even
prepare for the anal so you know there's
Dookie all over the place why would
anybody do that maybe look at all the
ship disappear that's [ __ ] gross
David Blaine nobody's like telling me
you should disappear and then after he's
done he's like its back yeah check your
mouth check your teeth she smiles
[Laughter]
Joe's not appalled at the Raven
[Laughter]
cuz I'm assuming if you want to if you
want to get some rape you know you mean
there's nothing funny about rape all I'm
saying is if you're trying to get some
rape you don't want to try yourself
yeah you know you Dookie all over
yourself you want it oh you try to you
try to get some things you know this was
stupid shame on you David Blaine shame
on you not for the rape she didn't clean
a [ __ ] yeah Jews do not condone rape by
the way I'm just trying to let the world
know that anal you have to prepare for
that people be watching pornos they
think that [ __ ] is hot because there's
so much annual going on do girls be
cleaning that booty hall dude and then
they prepare what not to eat all this
stuff they they gotta prep it
traumatized but let's keep going so she
first reported this November of 2016
why does she wait so long is a long time
because she was thinking for a long time
yeah so she's alleging that this
happened in June or July of 2004 when
she was 21 years old and so now Scotland
Yard has summoned David Blaine to the UK
for an interview under caution
[Music]
okay so then um so she's saying that she
met him at this nightclub in London and
the day after and so around this time
was when David had just been making it
big in the world of magic he he like had
suspended himself thirty feet above the
river the Thames river the Haven outfit
I don't know I think so
look at I thought he's done a lot of
crazy she did that for 44 days surviving
on a theme of water and so that's what
he did her on that time and so Blaine
was pictured in London in both June and
July of 2004 when like you know Natasha
was claiming that this happened so she's
saying that the night after or yeah the
night after that they had met he called
her to invite her to a party and when
she initially declined the offer he
ended up sending a car over to her so
she was like okay he must really like me
so I'll go and then so she ended up
going to this apartment and there was a
lot of people there and they were just
all heavy conversations and then some
time passed and then David disappeared
into the kitchen roughly 20 minutes
later and then he ended up oh no he got
back with the vodka soda and then after
they talked 20 minutes later he led her
into a bedroom told her to kiss him and
then told her to finish her drink and
then she just blacks out she doesn't
remember anything except for one moment
during intercourse when she said things
got so rough that she was woken up he
says this quote at some point I was on
the bed face forward and he was behind
me I think he woke me up a little bit
because I had never had that print to
see that anal sex done to me before oh
and she's saying that the next morning
she had to wake up to do a shoot for my
just a clothing brand and then that the
whole day was blurry and confusing and
that the next thing she remembers was
sitting and they makeup chair getting
her makeup done and thinking what did I
do last night did I have sex with David
Blaine but I didn't want to
I felt hazy completely out of it I don't
remember taking a shower where I changed
leaving his house or anything I think
the real evidence will be of share sore
bajo no cause like if you've never done
anal
it really hurts she had a really sore
butthole did I take a shower then I blow
dry my hair right
she should be thinking wait is my
butthole sore yeah if I was the judge
all right that's what I would ask her oh
Jesus
I'll be like so on the morning of the
incident when you woke up did you feel
any pain what was on the sheets remember
that no no what what does she remember
she does is she's so hazy she did next
thing she knows she's in a makeup chair
she doesn't remember like how she
laughed how she if she showered or not
I'll say okay did you notice anything on
not like abnormal and I don't want to
like shake the questions to make you say
anything so I just like did you notice
anything abnormal about yourself like
here do this or were there irregular
bowel movements where your farts quieter
than usual right and if she goes she
could be she she could be ashamed so she
didn't want to blatantly come out and
say it you know but then I'll just be
like yo we cool I'm I I know what that
long what you do yes
David Blaine's lawyer he so David Blaine
made a statement through his lawyer
saying my client vehemently denies that
he raped or sexually assaulted any woman
ever and he specifically denies raping a
woman in 2004 if in fact there is any
police investigation my client will
fully cooperate because he has nothing
to hide oh man because this would
include Natasha price you know what's
sad is that it could be David Blaine but
it could also be that during the party
there was a lot of people right yeah and
she could have got drunk pounded down
all these drinks got it from another guy
but all she remembers is right before
that first drink she also claims that
the sex a lot huh it was disappearing
during the sex life no then she had four
more encounters with Blaine after that
Oh Oh the first was when she was back in
New York and she says that he calls her
and that she was very freaked out he
seems to be checking up on me he sounded
very creepy and it made me feel a bit
fishy oh wait so she got roofied four
times after that no for me how many
counters okay so what else he called her
and then and then they ended up seeing
each other again the following year when
they were both invited to the same party
there she claims that he cornered her in
a bathroom and told her quote you were
really good in bed
Oh the next encounter came six years
later when she ran into him on the
subway in Manhattan while she was with
his girlfriend and her daughter and she
claims that they exchanged small talk
small talk but nothing more why she saw
him one final time after a few days
later when he appeared outside an art
gallery that she worked in and then and
then she was just saying that he calls
her he called her name and actually felt
embarrassed and invited him in what
well first of all why small talk and
second of all why even in like invite
him in I don't know did he go but ran it
by someone were even having small talk
with she probably gonna let it emit and
let him in he probably just appeared
magically inside yeah I mean okay um
you're not coming in that's funny
because I'm already here
I'm here yeah my question my I think the
hardest thing is that she waited 14 plus
years or some [ __ ] like that right to
actually come out about it now I can the
whole waiting thing that long I can you
understand can understand twelve no over
a deck and understand but uh early talk
to him like that and invite him in
that's a little bit weird yeah that's
actually an addition to this article
because they just they've been updating
it because it came out and so they also
added that she says she's coming forward
now about the alleged attacks because
she's been having like years of
flashbacks and felt bad it sucks
yeah and then because there is no
statute of limitations for sex crime in
Britain she says that she wants to
expose blame mm-hmm
yeah good job I wonder how they're gonna
prove that that's gonna be pretty rough
he's a hopefully good job if not then
you're ruining guy's career well I hope
he's not so finding all these women yeah
but we just know after Bill Cosby thing
there's a there's a possibility that is
true yeah what's up guys how do we do
did you like it did you hate it well
guess what there's only a like button
and if you liked it that's the way to
communicate that to us so make sure to
hit that like button and for more
episodes click right above me
[Music]